I cried so much from 1 to 8 from 0 8
Gary Vaynerchuk cried every day I was so
emotional my new hypothesis is the
following
you got your prospective
[Music]
YouTube what's up so so grateful that
you clicked and you're about to watch a
new youtube video but before you do -
one two nine three one five seven three
one that is my texting community
platform doing a lot of one-on-one
engagement in there and also access
opportunity first looks in that
environment - one two nine thirty one
five seven three one join it now and now
to the video you've been wanting to
watch hey guys it's Gary Vaynerchuk
episode three three one of the
askgaryvee show actually we had a pretty
hardcore team Gary meaning the other day
where we're actually gonna be rebranding
this show so a lot of changes in store
so one of the last askgaryvee shows in
this format are we keeping the house
Cherubini as anyway Amy a ton of [ __ ] is
coming as always and Amy is back in the
building
I'm gonna allow her to introduce herself
to the vaynernation in a minute
talk about this lovely book but uh I
think this is one of the last things I'm
doing content wise for the year so happy
happy holidays happy new year healthy to
everybody the new decade is upon us and
it's really good to see you Amy it's
great to see you Gary thanks for having
me Marsha tell everybody who you are and
a little bit about what we're doing here
sure
my name is Amy Landy no and I'm a veiner
speaker isn't that the only thing that
actually fun fact Amy is part of a nurse
speakers is a agency we have where we
wrapped me and I think 10 maybe you're
so other exclusive artists and then
others and Amy is part of the roster
were the first people we reached out I
am so grateful for that but have you
been enjoying it oh my gosh are you
kidding let's shoot it what a Cheney I
want to [ __ ] on Zach and daisies Albin
have they been good they've been
fantastic it's been you know it was at
the end of the first year I was like see
you guys are like cool with me staying
on right and they're like oh yeah we're
just getting started I mean it's only
gotten better as we've gone along you
guys sent me to Saudi Arabia for crying
out loud that's awesome but I think what
most people know me for is a youtube
channel called Amy TV I help women going
after the life that they want I also
have a podcast called detail therapy so
speaking I just wrote my second book
good morning good life and
when this come out just a couple weeks
ago self-published or self-published and
how's that game been oh it's a lot of
work from the outset but it's so worth
it in the end I mean it's just like
there I don't have to deal with anybody
it's just my book in a world were like
so many people producing content you
know what you just said is like
something I think about like there's so
much what do you think has helped you
succeed at the end of the day and I in
it goes back to the conversation of
should you publish traditionally should
you do a lot of things there's so many
different options but that's the best
part about it and also the worst part
about it it's paralyzing I think the
thing that's made me succeed is the
ability to make a decision I can make a
decision and just decide to do it and
whether it's the best thing I could have
done or I could have done something
better it's fine you reflect on it you
move on from it you go if I decide to
self publish and I'm like whom should
have done something who cares like
whatever progress is gonna no I don't
not at all because I know that I can
just do it again I can just try
something else I can just go a different
way and there's actually not a lot of
things I can think of where I'm like oh
man made the wrong move because I just
decide and go yeah I like that I'm a big
fan of that
we're gonna take some calls I decided
quite a bit on this episode so please
put what we live on Facebook okay and
LinkedIn all right cool LinkedIn
Facebook please put your phone number in
the comments and we will call you as
we're gonna make the majority the show
callin cuz I like that and I want to do
that and we've had Amy in the past so
you can google us we've jammed a bunch
over the years so yeah there's plenty
backstory and things that nature so
what's uh what are you hyped about what
are you excited about what's on your
mind like what are you thinking about
these days I don't know I actually kind
of had a like a tangent thought moment
this morning just because like I don't
think I've ever like sat down and like
fully like chatted with you in sort of
this kind of format but there's such a
misconception because you've been really
kind to me you've been great to my
career my family but a lot of people
have approached me and gone how are you
like best friends with Gary Vaynerchuk
and I'm just like well you know good
work observes good work and it ends up
being the best example ever when I'm
talking to people about mentorship
because everybody has this like not
everybody but a lot of people have the
wrong idea that you have to literally be
on the phone with some
talk to somebody every day every week
for X number of minutes in order for
them to mentor you but that's never been
the case with you being my mentor I read
your books I watched your videos I
listen to podcasts you told me what to
do all along but it's like how many
conversations do we need to have in
between and that was a moment I had this
morning I was like I wish more people
knew that I don't have to be your best
friend
to take a good example from you and I
hope that that's what is happening so if
that's what you mean with that
perspective like that I will think that
our relationship that they need to have
that same level of access to me to get
the benefit
theyed yeah any access and it it looks
different than it actually is and it's
because of someone's ability to execute
not what someone's actual access is I
agree I think it has a lot to do with
the first thing that you spoke about
which is your ability not to dwell hmm
helps you so much yeah like people
second-guess themselves beforehand and
after and that's where all the energy
goes as the linge themselves up it's a
game of insecurity versus self-esteem
this is this is one big game of that mmm
no matter how many different cartoons or
platforms or ways I package the story
it's very very very important for people
to understand the way they think about
themselves is it uncomfortable variable
to what's going to happen mm-hmm
absolutely I've been kind of having this
conversation with my community lately
about guilt because it comes in a lot of
different ways it's packaged in a lot of
different ways you can do it to yourself
but it can also be somebody else trying
to make you feel guilty and you'll
actually find that that happens a lot
when you're actually doing something to
improve yourself like having a morning
routine or starting a business or saving
money and not going out as much guilt
comes externally all the time but what
I'm realizing more and more is I can't
feel guilty about something that I'm
doing with intention something I chose
to do and so if I'm not able to do this
thing because I was able to focus on
what was important to me because there
is no shame attached to what I do and
how I spend my time every day that guilt
just doesn't make a connection to me and
I I don't know if that's like oh I lack
feelings in certain areas
or whatever but I just have been able to
compartmentalize a little bit where I
can observe someone's feelings if they
if they think I'm not hearing them and
say you know okay how do we fix the real
problem here because it's not that I'm
too invested in my career that's not
really the problem at the end of the day
but yeah I mean I think about that a lot
as well I think so much of what works
for me is having the ability to have
detachment with what you were just
referring to which is not having
feelings like the whole business is
business mm-hmm I know while having deep
empathy I have enormous compassion it's
very easy for me to understand but I
have a complete ability to not allow
somebody else to impose their feelings
on how I should be feeling yeah I just
I'm we live in a keyboard warrior
culture like it's it's laughable to me
that somebody who doesn't who's never
met me can have the energy to tell me
how to live my life a hundred percent
like oh it doesn't make like even in the
way I articulated that like it's just
common sense right there's like you know
but it leads to what is your framework
if you were brought up by parents that
made you feel insecure then it's likely
that Johnny pants 47 has a chance to
make you insecure as well in a comment
and not really even knowing when some
what it sounds like for someone to blame
you and then when you for you to take
that same habit forward and use a blame
mentality and an approach and making
somebody feel so feel that I just came
out of a really tough HR meeting where
somebody went to HR that's upset with me
about a decision I made that is 100%
grounded in their entitlement and ego
hmm and I want to punch something like
seriously like like that but like that's
my you know that's my that's it's just
really fascinating especially the reason
I have some juice on this is because on
top of which me bending triple backwards
to make it awesome for them hence why
the entitlement happened hmm but that's
the game it's yeah that's the balance
that I have people hate accountability
100% the balance for me learning as my
business grows is learning how to be a
manager and I'm like whoa this is
a thing I did not sign up for right and
so there's that and then there's like
okay I want them to see it this way but
like Who am I to say the way they see
things so Who am I to say that their ego
is not a good number you know you know
what's funny is that um I have so much
passion to share
I have zero expectations of anybody
consuming my content and acting on it
zero every single person that has gotten
benefit from it and it has told me has
been complete upside added value zero
expectations yeah back to Who am I yeah
yes I understand the people are reacting
to my content because I'm a good
communicator and I'd like to think I
have something of substance to say but I
don't expect it hmm
there's a lot of things going on there's
plenty of things and I think the good
communicators or the people that are
easy to son sort of understand and grab
on to there's a level of extreme that
has to be the case like clearly you you
exemplify extremity in some way I have
an extreme and in different things that
I do you you can't put somebody on every
single pedestal it's that extreme
there's different judgments for
different extremes I might be an extreme
with my extroverted you know
communication style and there's
judgement to that I get a lot of people
to your you know as you know that think
I'm full of [ __ ]
or a charlatan whereas somebody who's an
extremely good articulator of words
writing a beautifully extreme LinkedIn
article does not get that judgment mmm
like you know I'm always scared for
people to try to replicate my style the
only thing that works for me is I'm
incapable of not being myself and you
have the audacity to do it with on video
with audio like there's I think there's
a different emotional connection for an
audience cuz it feels like you're
talking to them on video if you if you
have achieved your goal as a video
creator it feels like you're sitting in
the room with someone and you're saying
that to their face and I think what's
important is just like leaning into you
like let it be known as a strategist for
success I wish my chemicals were 25%
less over the top there are people that
immediately within the first 40 seconds
of their friend recommending them
watching
content will click play leave DM their
friend or text and be like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about that I hate that
dude yeah if I could take 25% less juice
out of my communication style I would
have more audience it's not super
complicated
oh I don't know if I agree because
you're gonna argue the counter which I
probably agree with as well which is
where I was about to go which is but
then you don't have the audience you
have from your authenticity but not just
that
I mean clearly we see it in every
capacity and politics and everything
like your ability to make people make a
decision is where you end up getting
even more traction yeah
and to your point if there was 25 less
you know if there's one less curse or
there was a really just shortage and I
had with a really nice guy on my
Instagram two days ago I think or
yesterday where there's this moment
where I'm helping this kid make a
decision around doing what he loves
versus what his mom wants and in the
moment we're going back and forth and
I'm like he's like you're right and I'm
like I know I'm right and I'm
transitioning the next thing and he took
real issue and he's like I hate that
about you like you're soaked like
everything's so good and when you come
across condescending or high in yourself
I'm like you've completely missed the
context this is a kid in this exact
moment that's trying to make a life
decision and me creating affirmation on
his idea that wait a minute you might be
right is exactly what's neat in that
moment I don't need to say I'm right for
my own ego
I don't need to tell some random kid I
know um that's not the moment where I'm
gonna pull out the ego card I think
that's the segue to let me tell you
everything I feel like you should hear
right now
you're taking it personal when I say
people who literal word literal right
he's taking a little like we watch it we
watch it I know I'm right is to keep
pushing him down a path to try to help
him feel empowered that further not me
trying to be braggadocious I can be
braggadocious a million more interesting
ways resi sold for hundreds and hundreds
of millions of dollars to MX hundreds
and hundreds of millions of dollars
me and Ben Leventhal came up with the
idea over dinner we incubated the comp
vaynermedia i sat on the board I was an
instrumental player I rarely mention it
I was whatever I could be doing DM
exported for hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars there's a I'm so
much more interesting [ __ ] to be
braggadocious about than me being right
that his mom will be happy if he lives
his life his way people are very funny
very literal really willing to take
things out of context for the narrative
they want to paint hmm
let's take some phone numbers LinkedIn
Facebook put up your phone numbers
Junior here is gonna do some calls will
do it we want to get Amy to answer some
questions while John is dialing how's
the book doing it's great yes old for
you yeah we definitely sold some books
it's amazing because it's like I haven't
had to create any content on Instagram
like who's everybody's just don't worry
Ethan its Gary Vaynerchuk and you're on
the askgaryvee show with Amy oh my god
I've followed you my whole life how old
are you for real
22 I've been an entrepreneur my whole
life yeah when I was in high school huh
real quick say hello to Amy it's fine
Ethan how are you I'm doing great please
proceed with your story okay anyways I
am a total entrepreneurial kid you'd
been started a lawn mowing business when
I was little I started snow cone shock
in high school I came to college I
started at drinks and treats business in
Salt Lake City and I've all I do is work
dude and I'm I'm just been an
entrepreneur my whole life and you're
just my hero Gary thank you so much for
everything bro thank you so so much
you're welcome
do you have a question is there
something I mean I can answer yeah I do
have a question so I'm 22 I'm a bit
younger but I've built a pretty big
business here in Salt Lake like I'm
saying it's a drinking treat shop right
so what we sell is like um soda
and treats cookies cinnamon rolls
pretzels things to go with it right I
invent and we do most of our business
through the drive-through
there was a few location we
McCue location who do catering ed groans
pity I've owned the business I started
at four years ago I've owned the
business for about four years I've kind
of built my personal brand on the back
of my business contact so we have a
really popular Instagram page here and
so late
what's a call at it's at third to drink
tea HRSG DRI and chaos okay first drink
the business colors anyways
I'm always on there hey what up I call
it I call my head audience honestly dude
I risk meeting you I started calling you
so long ago I listen your content so
much I started calling my audience the
thirsty nation I'm always on the stories
everyday like thirsty nation what up we
got this product anyways people and I'm
always at the shop working 24/7 so I've
kind of built a personal brand like
indirectly from my business okay and but
I'm 20 I mean I'm 22 I'm wondering how I
can build a personal brand because to
kind of you know leverage this into the
next thing that I do you know I've built
my personal brand off of the back of my
businesses brand but the problem is I
struggle to put my finger on Rex my
personal content because I know I feel
like I know a lot of [ __ ] like I've been
love your intuitive your intuitive no
you're no different than I was at that
like so much of the reason that I've
innovated and been unique is I didn't
learn it it was intuitive I did it I saw
that it worked I talked about it they
answered questions very simple there's a
vaynermedia Instagram page there's a
Wine Library Instagram page there's an
empathy wines Instagram page there's
also a Gary Vee Instagram page you
should put your personal content on your
personal page what you need to get it
when you don't know III know I know
you're against like dude and I [ __ ]
hate I'm oh I'm like a brick-and-mortar
retail business entrepreneur a young one
real okay I can get okay but I know I'm
not I'm not building a social media
agency you know like I'm not a
bullshitter okay you know how many say
you know how many fake entrepreneurs are
putting out content about how you know
what's what's right but what's that got
to do with you like why why why don't
you have an Instagram page they that
you're putting out content on your page
I do but I struggle to put my finger on
where no no no let's
what where to put the content no know
what kind of content because why don't
you know you don't know you know journey
no you don't you really don't have like
I can tell it in these 3 minutes and 41
seconds that you do not have a problem
figuring out what to post on it you just
have too much to say I don't want to be
a bullshitter dude so don't ya I'm what
you think that people have you been
affected by me saying that don't be a 22
year old life coat are you like let me
so let's so let's good
so let's ship at it the people think
that I'm a motivational speaker I don't
want to be what's one of the ways to do
that
by building an actual 200 million dollar
agency what a thousand employees
globally to starting a speaking Bureau
that is actually good and Amy still
likes us we send her to Saudi Arabia
like like don't put out anything that
isn't true I feel like how do I have
might be grounds of that because I
didn't know you know anything like you
but like that's a million dollar
business you know just talk about talk
about what happened today when the
manager called out sick and you had to
go there I wish I made content when I
was building Wine Library there was real
ass [ __ ] there just like I would argue
that my running hypothesis is your
problem is that your account doesn't
have any followers yet and the and the
humility needed after you've built up
the businesses following count to start
yours now with no followers is a bridge
that's a little bit difficult to cross
right now I don't think so but I also on
that point you I have a tactic that I
kind of stems from your contest that I
think everyone's gonna really like I
created an account called Ethan from
thirst that's literally my username I
see it and I go in i go in and I engage
with the community my first drinks
community so when were saying with
something some comments I instead of
commenting back from thirst from thirst
account I'll go in from I got some from
third just from that little personal
touch just that extra author so what's
up so they know that the owner is caring
I love that I'm really doing this so
what so I believe it I see it
Amy did you have some and while I'm
looking I mean like my question is I we
know that document and creating content
is a great idea but at the same time
like why do you want to build the
personal brand like you directly
connected it to why Gary is doing it he
has an agency all of these assets help
him but at the same time I get it if if
the personal brands gonna help you in
some way you can't even fathom yet down
the road that's great but if you know
why you're going to talk to an audience
on a different site on a different
platform on a different account you'll
know who you're talking to a little bit
better because it does I don't it
doesn't sound to me like you're talking
to the thirst audience because that's
why you would post on the thirst account
why are you posting on Ethan's account
who are you talking to because the more
you look at the camera like it's a
person the more it's gonna feel like
you're connecting with them and you have
to know who that person is really well
in order to do that all right I want to
build up my brand cuz I guess I want the
leverage for the next run you know I'm
so sad like I've built a huge business
of it as a pretty young kid and I'm like
okay this is cool I want people to know
about it so that it can go to the next
thing I think I like I think that's
right and looking at your account my
question is what's the problem just
bring my content like should I share my
tips and tricks I only be having you
know ah let's see let's go back to that
point thank you for that let's really I
mean I'm not wondering I'm wondering do
I share my you know knowledge that a lot
you know it's like why why why wouldn't
you because I because of the
bullshitters out there you know no no no
no that it makes no sense to me let's
stay on this Ethan you wouldn't share
tactics that you've used to build up
your business because you're worried
that somebody who's full of [ __ ] that
makes pretender entrepreneur will do
what play with me here no I don't I
don't care about them I'm more I'm more
worried about me I like I don't wanna be
perceived as one of those just like just
like you're talking about oh your butt
your butt your butt your pudding you're
putting out content now like like I'm
looking at your content you you have a
post on your account of a screenshot
where you text somebody about you know
an increase of 50% in sales I don't
think you're worried about the [ __ ]
part I
you just might not actually want to
share the information because you might
think it's a competitive advantage no
all right so then why wouldn't you share
it I guess just because I dude I'm in
the mix of it like I'm I go to the
University Utah I leave you guys like
just bullshitting you know I'm like I'm
wildly confused why you think that
matters to you I see them - they all
copy me every day I think about them
zero why are you thinking about them if
it's a perception issue is it because
you only feel like you can post
something when you have a hard metric to
offer that can prove that you know what
you're doing and you don't feel like
talking in hyperbole other times cuz
it's like it could be perceived any
which way maybe I
but he's doing buddies that I am but but
you're doing it like but you post a
three-minute nine video titled it's not
about the likes comments or followers
and then there's gonna be three minutes
of you here talking into the mic you're
you're doing all the behaviors like you
look like a hot start to me the only
thing the only thing that keeps you from
not I look like a huckster to people -
bro the only thing that keeps one away
from not being a huckster is not being a
huckster
alright that's maybe why I'm I'm so
defensive about it cuz I'm like dude I
build a real business and I want to be
like I'm gonna bike I don't [ __ ] the
associate those people I'm like I'm the
real like you know you won't be
associated with them you built a
business you're not associated with them
know everybody thinks I'm exactly like
some of the people that are the worst
hucksters of them all there's nothing I
can do about that
that's on them if you're it like you're
just worried about other people's
opinions way too much which is really
funny to me because if the why is that
you want to leverage this in the future
that's based on other people's opinions
so I feel like you need to kind of draw
the line I think we talked about it a
little bit before the call if you're
making this decision if you don't have
any shame in what you're doing if you're
a success at it and you want to show it
to the world it's very easy to let
everyone's now opinions you know keep
you from doing something but then
bandwagon once it gets going people will
jump on board but you got it you got to
keep it anything I have a news report
for you if you don't make content the
hucksters are gonna keep making content
so what are we doing here the [ __ ] are
you accomplishing we're building real
businesses out here man so build it so
let's go back to why you're asking me go
ahead I saw you want to say something
well so now it's like you don't want to
look like everybody else that's a
huckster and there you go but you're
using your ego as an excuse as to why
you're not going to share it because
you're like oh I'm doing real business
over here I can't possibly make the time
to talk about it but you can because you
know it's valuable because you're
smarter than that so it doesn't feel
like I'm insecure
I mean I've branded myself as this
little soda shop boy that sells - mom -
coming the dress you I'm not worried
about it that way I guess I guess I in
parallel I'm asking like how do I do
this - because I'm running a small
business I can't I can't hire a d-roc
you know like you do and we do it mom
yeah I thought no no but pro the bro
let's just take a step back like like
this is real life now like when I
started doing Twitter in 2007 Wine
Library was doing 50 plus million
dollars in business I was super busy had
a hundred employees and I did all my own
social media made content and engage
with community I just went to sleep at 3
o'clock in the morning cuz I was trying
to win the whole [ __ ] thing now I
don't recommend that for everybody like
not everybody wants that not everybody
does that like but but it's doable like
I don't know what you're talking about
there's people running way bigger
businesses than you at the same age who
are making content like it's not super
quiet like the question becomes I think
that there's some stuff that you have to
get real with yourself on about it a you
know the truth is undefeated so
regardless of what I say or you say or
we say or Amy says or they say in the
comments if you're a real entrepreneur
and you build a real business that's how
it's gonna play out right B I think
you're you especially if you're
following me this your whole life for
years like you know how valuable
personal brand can be for leverage I
think you're on the right track I think
that you might be better at being an
entrepreneur than you are at being a
content creator and communicator or
you're lacking patience or you do over
value judgment or you'd like to see more
track
and it's you know causing friction all
these things are real conversations
which are all fine you just have to get
it
listening to this and when you watch
these 30 minutes back the complete
unlock because we asked all the right
questions is gonna be where do you need
to get real with yourself that you
didn't get in this call I promise you
Ethan that is the answer mm-hmm thank
you so much Gary either one thing that
might help you is go back and watch go
back and look at all my tweets from 2007
I'll take you 15 minutes but go back and
find that the team did this recently I
think one of them I tweet they used in
the content I got two likes
no no retweets no comments two likes you
know somewhere none Thank You Dustin
like you know what everyone asked me
because I'm yelling about text because
it's just blowing up my business right
now text marketing is yep how does it
how do you do you know how it fits into
a small business because it's kind of
expensive for for a small business like
it cost me five cents of text to send
these out I know you're yelling about it
you know anything is your team know
anything about how this can work for
small businesses because you find if I
have a ten thousand person text list at
500 bucks yeah well you haven't
amortized out the value in return yet no
I
yeah I feel but I'm just wondering real
quick real quick you see it how many
ready let's be real I think you like
this how many people are on text
platform right now I can about almost
11,000 text is it worth is it worth $500
a text for you a couple times a month
but I it worked so good my my customers
love it so much I'm trying to figure are
you selling on it or is it or is it you
using it as as a service to them I'll
use it as a hey this weekend we're gonna
have to be baking fresh soft pretzels
we'd love to see you have a great
weekend and picture of the pretzels
something like that yes so I think a I
think five cents of text is too
expensive from what I can recall in my
head like for example actually actually
it actually you're gonna love me right
now I'm literally gonna give you a real
piece of data there was a text we sent
out that's
you just want to make sure I get this
give me 40 seconds actually it won't be
here no give me 40 seconds
Amy keep him lucky but I I mean like
that to me it sounds like it's working
great and I'm curious to hear like what
the issue is it's expensive absolutely
but if it's bringing you business if
you've seen if you've seen a movable
difference are you seeing more than a
500 hour difference that weekend thank
you you think I was handing out free
money when I send out these back honest
I don't I even sent me an email send me
an email to Gary at vaynermedia we sent
out ninety one hundred ninety one ninety
one ninety one text today cost us two
eight to forty eight seventy two so you
might just be going with a service
provider that's got a premium so right
there we've saved you two hundred fifty
bucks a text this is for your following
q gary solo no allow them are small
businesses if you export that your POS
data ninety percent of the time the
house phone numbers in it yeah and you
text those customers they will come
running back i got that from you it in
it you better you better make sure that
your compliance though like you don't
extract the numbers and text cold
because there's a lot of compliance
issues with texting for everybody's
listing so I think I kill this industry
I think you want us I think what you
want to do there if you're making a if
you're make yeah if you make a prod if
you make a promise up front that you're
gonna text people are open to letting
their text open even rewatch this and
deploy deploy some true answers to
yourself about it and go execute thank
you come on Harry
bye-bye let's get another : that was fun
it's really interesting I mean I think
you know what's fun about that call is
there's a lot of good ingredients there
100% right and he's 22 it's amazing and
he's got it
yeah like he built a [ __ ] business
already a real life like I mean like
real he's hitting the ground running
it's so easy to get tripped up by
opinions especially this young in life
but in general he's probably he wants to
build up a much bigger social media
platform but he doesn't want to push
back hello Calvin Calvin this is Gavin
with Calvin this is Gary Bainer
how are you Calvin doing well
good to be back on the show thanks come
so Gary I asked you on Episode two or
two about celebrating and I think Amy
asks you something around it wants to
about like how do you get the energy
back after doing something big both of
you guys are up to really big things
Calvin's on it around this time of year
we have so many people about $0.02
neared resolutions yes and aiming bigger
and I'm just curious for both of you Amy
and Gary like first of all what are you
celebrating right now to end 2019 and
more importantly Howard your sights now
set on 2020 like how do you go that how
do you vision that like what's going on
you first thing I mean I'm excited about
my new book that's pretty much my 2019 I
mean like the end of a decade this is
our heyday at Amy TV like January new
year new me it's a new decade like we're
just gonna have so much fun with that
but you also can't get so engrossed in
that it's very easy to have New Year's
resolutions it's totally different thing
to execute and and to actually stick
with something I have it isn't a habit
because you called it a habit it's a
habit because it becomes a habitual so
yeah so I think that's um that's a lot
of what's in front of me I mean like is
helping people understand that they
actually have the time to do the things
that they want to do if they care about
it that much
and I Gary you've talked about this ad
nauseam how late are you watching
Netflix at night what could you be doing
by the way it's very easy to get seven
hours of sleep if you know you're you
want to wake up early and do the thing
that you want to do and I have such a
totally different perspective I think
about where I was ten years ago it's
probably when I discovered Gary red
crush it in 2009 a totally different
place in my life I've had tragedy happen
I've had beautiful things happen I've
had high of highs happen I just wrote my
second book which is really weird I'm
I'm very excited to be able to take what
I've learned in the especially in the
last couple of years into the next stage
in my life because I think it's the best
place that my headspace could be right
now to be realistic about the fact that
we're so lucky to breathe every day yeah
um there is no micro event resi selling
or
or Vayner being positioned for a big
year or a sneaker deal a car deal a wine
company like there's no micro event even
even family stuff kids getting older you
know family time even that I call a
micro event
I don't celebrate because I'm always
celebrating I don't I don't celebrate
micro I truly celebrate macro I'm
literally one of these people you know
it's funny I'm not religious but I'm
definitely spiritual like I literally
wake up and I'm like you're not talking
about this enough Gary I just want to
say yeah I greet like that like you're
the spiritual side and things like that
you know it's funny because you know
it's funny I'm trying to find different
angles to say the same thing because I
want I'm hoping to use something even
the way you're reacting Calvin you're on
your [ __ ] if you knew - OH - and you
knew it you asked me that question so
you're consuming and you have context
and you're right I don't know if I've
ever even used spiritual I think maybe
one other time if I'm like kind of
feeling it uh the reason I'm saying that
is I don't think people hear me I really
mean it when I say that I woke up this
morning and I was like you know phone
call in the middle of the night that I'm
to run to the hospital for you yeah
super pumped I'm not in heaven right now
cuz that you know that brain hemorrhage
honest [ __ ] to do like you know like
like I I don't celebrate because I'm
actually celebrating and it's kind of
how I think about meditating and it's
how I kind of think about balance like
I've got some gear inside of me that has
a deep perspective that puts me in such
a good place that I'm celebrating
everything and nothing you know and
that's that like I don't know like
everything's fine yeah that's so
interesting is thinking about you though
is a lot of people get that from
something usually they usually get that
from their religion maybe they found yes
true or they read something you haven't
done any of that [ __ ]
I found it within myself you know what's
funny I've been thinking about lately
this thought was I so deep I cried so
much from 1 to 8 from 0 8 Gary
Vaynerchuk cried every day I was
so emotional my new hypothesis is the
following huh
I am so empathetic and when I say crying
when I was sad when my mom was sad when
I saw somebody else was sad left like
watching a movie TV I didn't like the
way that person got picked on in first
grade I cry like literally this is seen
in my head right now
somebody get I know what it is a kid got
picked on in class I see it I just are
crying my belief is that I might be so
empathetic you like people a lot that I
think I started building a reverse
behavior of detachment to even get
through by being so empathetic I became
that I created some sort of thing within
myself that made me go the complete
other way to make life palpable and I
practiced it so hard and that I probably
was naturally born so empathetic and
that my counter-reaction was to detach
myself from those feelings that I'm now
playing at such a bridge of I don't give
a [ __ ] I care about everybody this is
what I've always been confused about
with you cuz I'm I feel like I'm like I
operate it's very similar levels and you
all the time but I am a hundred percent
introverted I know how to be on when I
need to be on I love connecting with
people in a conversation I don't need to
look at my I would I would argue I have
been traumatic characteristics I'm
wildly good at being by myself that's
like you're what both you're a hundred
percent both and I'm real extreme on
both to like I think I recognize that in
you too and like my and it's not it's
not like it's not better or worse I
think you might be here and I might be
here and in that is even something
because I definitely know what happens
in between this and this that that's my
that's my theory right now I think I got
it from within myself out of out of a
correction of maybe being to feelings
oriented early on and then I think it
became patterns and building and
building and building I'm telling you I
couldn't explain to everybody here
enough of how much crying I did in the
first five to eight years of my life I
was
constantly crying I cried every time I
lost in anything until I was like 15
it's weird when you're 13 with your
buddies you lose in like you know like
in like like Nintendo football and
you're like crying and like punching
wall like I could I was I'm hyper on
emotionally and I think to get through I
created well you learned that it didn't
do anything it sounds like yeah or like
it was exhausting yeah right okay so you
know what's he still doing that's funny
that one who just said that like I went
into a place of like no I think it was
exhausting yeah and I think that's why I
am I could tie that to goal setting yes
you mentioned I want to be the number
one person on earth I don't give a [ __ ]
if nothing happens that's it you're in
that good you're in that good balance so
when you have a new year so you have
this big macro thing of some day buying
the New York Jets yes and there's that
and then you're in the train but that's
a front for me just to keep playing
forever so easy to latch on to it's not
the thing it's like a lease thing
thinking like a process of trying and
then like there's why I'm still going
guy yes L don't on the judge my question
is with a new year coming up I know you
usually take time off at the end or are
you actually planning and making up
goals for 2020 or you know like what's
what can come in a day no that's right
but I'm a plan the next 15 years on an
insight that I pick up on March 16th
walking down to my car at 6:03 p.m.
during a rainstorm and might say wait a
minute I'm in complete and utter motion
at all times I'm in strategy all the
time I don't sit down and write out it
on paper and say oh these last three
years and by the way that's my strength
of my weakness I just still think I'm
early I eat my own advice I believe at
44 years old that I'm not in panic mode
on my great ambitions how about you Amy
I mean like I I look at my goals every
single day and they mattered they matter
to me I'm rewriting them every day but
at the same time I feel like there
my version of the Jets like I enjoy
everything I'm doing on a daily basis if
my goals change in a couple of days or a
couple weeks a couple months it doesn't
completely rock my world because I know
I'm constantly moving forward I think
the problem becomes if you become so
much of a goal person or resolutions
person but you're never actually hitting
any marks that can be troubling that can
be difficult but I I feel very much on
the same page as Gary that it's like
these are helping me to make sure I stay
on point with my why they're helping me
to not get distracted by whatever I saw
on Instagram that looks cool like okay
cool that's my new goal no it's not it's
somebody else's and it's okay to be
happy for them but having something that
I know drives me to focus on keeps me
focused every day so I'm not getting
into the nitty-gritty and all the
drama's of the day but then really I'm
happy to take everything in stride the
way that it goes because that's [ __ ]
life it is like like my exact thing
about the fact that you took on college
debt because now you listen to me you're
like [ __ ] he's right like so now why
there's no [ __ ] time machine like can
we just [ __ ] go there once and for
all there is no time machine you're not
going into a time machine and every
second you dwell about something that
has already happened or completely out
of your control is a second you're not
using on the solution and also the news
is just like loving that you're sitting
on this because they're like hey hey we
might forgive all student debt we might
and you could qualify I'm not sitting
here waiting to see how that works out
for somebody it's like you've got to
make that change on your own and maybe
if something good happens along the way
it's cuz you were working so hard at it
on the day to day wiping out somebody's
mistake is the quickest way to make sure
they make a you do not learn like what
questions all to Amy if I can okay so
Amy first of all congratulations for
being a part of Boehner speakers that's
whipping around
thank you my question is for some of us
new guys that are just up and comers
what what advice would you give or how
to get signed with something like
Boehner speakers to turn up I mean I'm
doing I've been doing
a little bit of public speaking to last
couple of years that I want to turn it
up like a lot and so I'm just curious
what advice you'd have to either be
signed with an agency like Boehner
speakers or yes just what would you do
this
dumare speaking getting signed with an
agency was never really on my radar I
think I knew that there was something
like that would be advantageous to that
but never in my wildest dreams and I
think oh it's gonna be my buddy Gary
that starts at agency and so I have two
answers a get a significant other that
will tweet Gary and be like why is it a
me on your speaking roster cuz shout-out
to Vinny he's my number one honestly I'm
gonna give a counter to that Vinny's
probably the biggest reason Amy doesn't
have more opportunities with me because
he's bugging the [ __ ] out of me and
every time he moves me alone I actually
give Amy [ __ ]
I'm joking that was just did he go I'm
sorry I'm sorry to run it because I cuz
I actually like the way you communicate
so I actually think you've got a shot
here whatever great advice Amy's about
to give I just really want you to know
the answers content Calvin when I when I
wanted to take speaking seriously I did
I I in 2015 I was like if anyone allows
me to speak from an application or asked
me to speak I'm gonna pay whatever it
takes to get there that's where I went
to the Philippines I went to Manchester
UK I went everywhere and I spoke on 15
16 17 stages that year I spent a lot of
money and travel but I got experience
and then what happened people watch you
on YouTube for whatever reason they
think you can talk to a thousand people
in an audience when you're sitting alone
in a bedroom talking to a camera but it
still worked out content in that
capacity plus actually getting out and
getting experience and then everybody
was like you got it write a book so that
I have that piece down where I have
experience I've got to be on some some
stages spoken Salt Lake City last year
with Mel Robbins Tom dill you Jay Shetty
and a few others but it's just not that
much you like it go like I like go do
you mail I emailed every single tech
conference when I was doing Wine Library
TV I emailed every single tech
conference that I could get on a Google
Alert and email them and ask them if
they would have me to speak okay so
don't annoy you but go ahead and I
just go recap everybody up that's the
way to get in or annoy me no game is
about asked at and at the end of the day
like there's not gonna be one clear-cut
way it's the loudest person still wins a
lot of the time like they if they are
consistent if they're persistent and the
one thing that I've always had this I've
had staying power like for me if I'm
just talking about me at this point I
have been producing content for ten
years I have stuck around it's not been
when are you gonna give up on YouTube
I'm not giving up on YouTube until they
give up on the world like I'm just gonna
keep doing what I know how to do in the
best capacity that I know how I promise
you especially now where everybody's
talking about how what's the word not
good not super busy super crazy the
amount of content that's out there is
just it's a lot it's saturated and
that's a great excuse but it's also kind
of true but if you hang tight on what
your thing is and you're the best at it
and you just keep staying there and
you're the last guy standing at the end
of the day like someone's gonna discover
you if nothing else or you're sucked out
it I could paint every day I don't know
that's my intuition it's like I'll be
decent like you know I ended up being
great at speaking like you know but
Calment I think you need to put more
raps in you like you know take it
bothering an agent like here's where
everybody makes a mistake Vayner
speakers CAA William Morris please sign
me so you do the work for me and it's
easy yeah what you need to do I think
well I guess what you need to do is you
need to email every single conference
all of them Wow
do you need another speaker well do you
need another speaker do you need another
speaker everybody wants you need
somebody to introduce your speakers yeah
like just do anything it's work it takes
years and years and years like I've just
so funny with like obviously both of you
know this and now I'm looking at your
photo so I know exactly what we're
talking to like Calvin you know this Amy
knows this I've been doing this for a
long long long long time like now it
seems like all your friends like now
people really do know me like I've
definitely taken that next step in the
last 24 to 36 months but but both of you
knew I was a little I was a big deal in
our little circle right but you know
like they're all different steps and
before that I wasn't a big deal
little circle and I was a wine retailer
watching you go on the on The Tonight
Show and and do wine feels like a
nostalgic moment we're all reflecting on
from the former life it's not like
always on felon it's like always doing
this again everybody kept wondering
who's hosting this you want to hear
something you wanna hear something
really really funny they cut it out but
we're doing the skin yeah it was really
funny to that point we're doing the skit
and I and I see the producers say one
more minute and I go and Jimmy's like
doing something I'm like Jimmy he like
like let's hurry up here we got about 30
seconds and he just like turn to Vegas
the hell is my show they took it out I
thought they're gonna keep it it was
even worse than you think they edited it
to the best of their abilities I mean
look when I see the producers I just
know speaking which we gotta get the
[ __ ] out of here Calvin love you see you
bye
Amy thank you so much everybody's
watching please some more support this
wonderful woman who I think has a lot of
perspectives that I obviously resonate
with and more importantly just like
there was a single piece of content that
was the 87th time you heard me say it
but in that way it broke through my
intuition is for a far majority of you
that I've not been able to break through
or paint the picture maybe this book
does and so I assume it's super under 20
bucks support Amy's book would mean a
lot to me that would be your Christmas
present to me so see ya thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]